oh here in a sri lankan river this hunky
male monitor lizzard he is cozying up to
a female but she's been seen around town
with this dominant male now that looks
like flirting if ever I saw which
naturally means some serious male
posturing is in order and that leads
immediately to a water monitor wrestling
match he's one of these guys is like a
real-life Godzilla at 8 feet tall they
power over mere humans and would crush
one of us with a body clinched like this
oldest grappling is designed to leave
one lizard standing and he's the one who
will get the girl these awesome dragons
can keep this up for 45 minutes
the ruling monitor lizard finally
re-emphasizes his dominance the doe-eyed
female lizard thinks my hero he tries a
little of gentle persuasion seduction
monitor lizard style
he persevered and she accepts it she'll
produce up to 40 eggs a year in two or
more clutches and the genes of mr. big
stuff her hero will survive